la cuenta atrás para que se comience a
distribuir la vacuna contra el commit 19
está siendo clave para donald trump
el presidente saliente quiere anotarse
este logro de cara al futuro y para ello
organizó una cumbre para coordinar la
distribución de la vacuna en el país en
ella reconoció que está presionando a la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos fda por sus siglas en inglés
para que dé el visto bueno a los
fármacos y vaticinó una distribución en
tiempo récord
we just estamos a sólo unos días de la
autorización de la fed y los estamos
presionando mucho después comenzaremos
con la distribución masiva
si se autoriza decenas de millones de
dosis estarán disponibles este mes y las
distribuiremos rápidamente pero esta
cumbre contó con importantes ausencias
tanto pzifer como modernas declinaron la
invitación algo llamativo ya que serán
las dos principales farmacéuticas que
distribuirán vacunas en el país tampoco
hubo un representante del equipo del
presidente electo joe biden algo que
trump justificó aludiendo de nuevo a sus
acusaciones de fraude electoral
tenemos que ver cuál será la próxima
administración porque nosotros ganamos
en esos estados spend the job aiden por
su parte aportó otras cifras
su intención es aplicar 100 millones de
dosis en sus 100 primeros días al cargo
destino hub gateway de este equipo
ayudará a que al menos 100 millones de
inyecciones contra el cómic 19 lleguen a
los brazos del pueblo estadounidense en
los primeros 100 días 100 millones de
inyecciones en los primeros 100 días
king live' tan sólo ha dado una
aprobación preliminar a la dosis de
fisher y bryant y se espera que se
pronuncie sobre moderna el 17 de
diciembre